Mark Ingram of the Saints back here how
are you mark I'm good rich man how you
doing I'm fine I'm about that that your
offensive lineman's calling play-by-play
right you know that was my right tackle
for seven years of my career man so to
hear him calling the highlights and
calling the touchdown you know for us
that's crazy man but he's doing a real
good job I like hearing his voice call
to play that's right you tie Joe horn
for the record fifth fifth most
touchdowns in Saints history where are
you were you planning on maybe planting
a cell phone underneath the the uprights
to celebrate insert win if I had if I
had known that I was you know about the
tie Joe horn maybe I would've threw it
you know a little flip self on the front
of the goal you know I wasn't aware but
uh you know it's just appreciate you
know I'm honored and humbled that not to
be mentioned with you know some of the
top guys in st. sister II so shout out
to Joe horn man you know he's a legend
for putting the flip phone under under
the eye just shows you how long it's
been that he did he hey it's flip phone
that's how long it's been a flip phone
which I'm told Andrew Luck still uses
who knows so how does it feel to be back
in the mix mark it was really good to be
back with my teammates feedback with my
squad you know they was holding it down
and we was able to reload while I was
gone so I was working my butt off to
make sure I was ready when I got back so
I could
there's make our team stronger and we're
hurt my vote
where were you during that four day for
its four-game stretch where you were
season so like that right Beach
Boca ratone area that's where I was that
training you know just kind of going
through my offseason training with my
trainers but just you know keeping my
pads on keeping my helmet on working on
my you know catching the catching passes
working on my seat we're gonna must be
working on my conditioning I was just
working man just making sure I was ready
to go it was my time to get back what
did you learn from the sit down from the
league mark did you learn anything glean
anything yeah it made me hungry it's
just you can't take this game for
granted you know I love it with all my
heart man ever since I was look here so
just to be able just not
my team not to be be there you know
preparing working with them you know I
it made me hungry man made me appreciate
this game not taking anything for
granted I take any day for granted man
so it just made me hungrier and way more
appreciative and I'm excited to be back
with you guys okay and do you think the
the system was fair do you think the
league system was fair with you Mark
Ingram you know I'm just trying to move
on past it you know it was a tough
situation you know like I said a while
ago I didn't really agree with you know
everything that happened but you know
it's over with now so it really doesn't
even matter but it did okay so moving
forward then mark before we move forward
looking back one one one more game what
was it like being on the field or being
right there when Drew Brees set the
record that Monday he's done my guys in
my quarterback since my rookie year so
I've seen him you know break the number
of records have a number of milestones
that he's accomplished but for him to be
the all-time passing leader and to be
able to witness it on the field with him
on a Monday night game in the fashion
that he did on a long touchdown pass it
was only right for Drew and he's such a
hard worker such a great person such a
great teammate the most down-to-earth
humble individual you're meeting he just
puts in so much work day in and day out
so for him to be able to reach that
milestone all-time passing yards leader
NFL history it I'm super excited to him
he deserves it and he's the best ever to
do it so yeah I'm all my dad vacations
well much has made marking room about
Alabama sending Pro ready kids to the
next level what did you when you came
out of Alabama learn or glean as a
rookie from Drew Brees that you still
carry today
they just had a beer professional just
how to come in and prepare yourself day
in and day out to be the best you you
could be for the team he was just in
there everything good morning I see him
you know you try to get there early he's
in there watching film already he's
doing the same routine before practice
he he's going through every single read
you know in rice on air and team reps he
just showed up you how to be a pro he
showed you how to take care of your body
anything you needed to know man just
look for drill he listened to all these
great veteran that I had around me you
know other guys like Will Smith run the
Harper last more Marquez coaster and
there's a number of guys who you know
that were veterans that kind of showed
me the way me and cam Jordan when we
were rookies man and it was just a
blessing to have guys like that to learn
from and grow from and I've been able to
grow with Drew for eight years and I
appreciate that guy more than anything
because like you said man he just he
just showed you how to be a pro he leads
by example if you need this he goes
encouraged and he's always positive
never never never negative towards a
teammate or towards any situation so
there's a blessing to be able to have
women quarterback from our career and so
what what give me your favorite story of
him in the huddle whether it's a
comeback or just a a really pressurized
play where he came in and did something
I go give me give me your favorite brief
story if you have one law and there's a
million through three stories man but I
remember one time I remember one time he
dropped back man he something must have
happened with the communication of the
protection because we had somebody come
scot-free man and just blow drew up he
blew drew up and we all went over there
tried to pick him up his lip was
bleeding his lip was bleeding but like
next play right he wasn't mad he wasn't
frustrated his lip was still bloody he
called the play and I think we was able
to go for a touchdown the next drive but
it just shows like the grit he had the
toughness of him you know just for your
team to blow protection and you get
blown up the franchise QB
guy who we know we can't let him get hit
we know we can't let him be SEC I think
it's the first Titans maybe like three
years ago but I think a rack poking free
off the edge blue drew up lip bleeding
you know his head was ringing and uh you
know he got back with that huddle card
to play for us and I was able to get her
first down and and goes for a touchdown
on that drive so just that grit you know
that he has it's admirable and when your
quarterback is bleeding in his mouth was
bleeding out his lip but still calling
the playing still able to focus and
still be able to put his team in
position to have success I think that
just said a lot about his character and
how tough he is man but I have a man
thousand drew brees stories that we
could talk about for know without I bet
so have you ever in a quiet moment
brought up with Nick Saban being a
national champion and Heisman Trophy
winner out of Alabama having the
standing to ask Nick Saban what happened
in Miami why he and jewel breeze didn't
connect there the stable about that man
I never have but uh I think that's gonna
be on my short list with him since you
bring it up I'm gonna have to press him
about this situation yeah well I mean
how did you it helped you it helped you
I know I'm not mad that it did work out
you know Alabama wouldn't be what is it
say you know nor the Saints it's a
win-win enjoy the fruits of both of them
so I'm excited about that you know I got
this because the dolphin didn't get Drew
Brees
you know I got to go to Alabama because
I want you know possibly Greg's college
football coach ever and then I got to
get dressed to the tanks where you know
I got to play with you know probably
best quarterback to ever play the game
so I get to enjoy the fruits of both
from that decision so I'm happy about
that few more minutes left here with
Mark Ingram on the Rich Eisen show so is
it safe to say - against your Heisman
vote
here Marco - uh Coolidge it has my vote
that do it is ridiculous you know he he
only think he'd play boiler to half
quarters and he's probably the highs in
the front-runner
we're asking around here for Heisman
front-runner has ever had the
second-most snaps at quarterback on his
team
we're wondering not about that I highly
doubt that there's no way right it's uh
it's unbeliev
normal Noah but he's not normal he's not
normal really mark I mean I his deep
ball is so beautiful and then then
there's the rest of his game I mean he's
unbeliev
you could just tell you know he was very
polished coming out of high school as
far as passing the ball man and you can
just tell and he's growing and he's
learning every single game which is
trouble for the rest of them you know in
cheedo Blake wrote I'd and grow to its
role too so last thing for you here I
want to I want to delve into your
relationship with Alvin camara here
because you guys are sharing footballs
you're back to you're back in the mix
and he was a bell cow for the team for
four games then nine touches what is
your relationship like with him well my
little brother man ever since he came in
last year he was just you know he was
humble he's done earth if he needed to
learn he was just willing to learn
willing to do whatever it took to you
know be the best he could be and he
didn't think he knew everything he
didn't feel like he was entitled he just
he just worked and we just developed the
friendship developed a relationship
developed a bond
he went to Alabama so I knew him from
men you know he transferred to Tennessee
of course but you know he would he's a
crescent tire guy you know he's one of
us even though he didn't stay so we had
that relationship but man we just cool
man we don't have any animosity we want
to see try to do well we want to see
each other have great success and we
want to do you know things I've never
been done we're gonna be the best
backfield you know ever play in the
league man we just keep pushing each
other that way man competition breeds
excellence and we compete but we're we
compete verse each other but we also
support each other so I think that's
really healthy and you know we're
appreciative of each other's Talon
and how about how we go about each other
how about how we go about each day and
working and putting ourselves in a
position to help this team win games man
so that's my bro and that's my do for
likely who's the whose idea has it been
to do postgame interviews together like
you did last Monday one game I think we
both had you know pretty good game and
we just kind of did it
you know we our lockers are right by
each other all the time and I think we
were both just getting dressing both
already at the same time and the the
slew of media was right there and we
just kind of started it then you know I
think would like to fit fourth or fifth
game last year fifth or sixth game last
year we started doing it we've been
doing it like that ever since our
lockers are right by each other and
we're usually finishing getting ready
around the same time so when the group
when the crowd of media comes over we
just say hey man you know it's time for
our interview nice who leads and touches
though who leads they're who gets the
first answer and in that usually it kind
of just depends on how to gain weight
you know if he went for like 200
scrimmage yards and three TVs if I get
the first question so if I had you know
100 rushing yards to rush CDs I might
get the first question but you know it
doesn't really matter it's all good man
that's my guy and how does taste him
he'll get in this no I mean hazing
coming hey somebody what what's the
nicknames give me that again pay some
true
hey somebody you know hey that's great
I mean that that is fantastic the man
he's the man we love running that
redocking with him in the gang you know
we love that I know I wish he left it in
the hands of Alvin Camaro last last time
because I mean yeah yeah he'd hit his
head on the goalpost you eat it I don't
know if that's brought up and in a yeah
any any film session because you can't
tell mark this is how much I really
appreciate you and you know I've known
you for a long time and I love having
you on the show as I'm um I'm a guy who
has Alvin Kamara and fantasy I'm not
gonna lie
that
Monday night return of yours kind of
left a mark on my fantasy team you know
what I mean yeah
trippin out about the fantasy player I'm
one of those I'm sorry rich I apologize
I had I had Gordon TV man I had okay for
your personal and professional
well-being is what you're saying for my
reality not my fantasy you know I mean
well even though there may be an
iron-rich and Eisen mark I'm a team
player and it comes to you so I accept
your apology and I say congratulations
to you on those touch now are you saying
before I let you go that alvin kamara is
gonna root for Alabama over Tennessee
this week because he's such a Crimson
guys that we were saying I don't think
he's gonna roof out them all over
Tennessee okay but he knows he knows you
know he has crimson blood and he knows
what you know what what comes with that
mark you can carry yourself Matt all
right thanks for the call we'll chat
again soon Mark Ingram at Mark Ingram 22
on Twitter so Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience